[Music]
let's all take a journey back in time to
that first
curious fish who crawled out of the
ocean onto that warm sandy beach
about 400 million years ago first off
what a crazy experience that must have
been for the fish
i imagine they're turning around looking
lost being like
hey uh do you guys know there's a whole
world out here
so that first fish was essentially the
iphone 1 of land animals
it was a prototype a minimum viable
product
it was really exciting but definitely
not perfect
but each generation that fishes kids got
better at surviving
bigger lungs and feet and pretty soon
they were running instead of swimming
in essence they iterated through
evolution
so why does that sound so familiar at a
business school
it's because evolution is just finding
product market fit
let me say that again evolution is just
finding product market fit
now we have everything from beavers to
butterflies each one unique and
incredibly well adapted
to what it does okay yes i know
butterflies flutter around a little bit
but
i don't see you with a drone that can
run on nectar
so how can we draw insights from nature
to design our own technology the answer
is biomimicry biomimicry
is nature inspired innovation and it is
incredibly overlooked opportunity for
humanity my name is benjamin cramer
and i'm an mba student here at the gsb
and today
we're going to talk about how biomimicry
could be the key to unlocking some of
society's greatest technical challenges
so first let's start with a couple
examples so you can see what i'm talking
about
there's a crisp autumn morning in the
1940s and a french man
was out walking his dog the same path
they walked every day
and his dog took off into the bushes
when it came back a couple minutes later
wagging his tail and very proud of
himself
the man noticed that there was a couple
birds stuck in his dog's fur
and as he knelt over pulling each one
out one by one
the craziest thing happened he had an
epiphany
what if the little hooks holding these
seeds to my dog's fur
could be used to hold fabric together
without that insight we wouldn't have
velcro
and we'd be stuck tying shoes for every
five-year-old in the country
i had my own velcro moment about 10
years ago
i was hiking with my dad and brother in
zion national park
it was a warm summer's day one of those
that feels timeless
when i look down to see a little spider
hanging from a thread on my arm
and i thought to myself could we milk
spiders for thread my dad
ever the pragmatist pointed out that
milking spiders did not seem like the
best business model
and he was totally right so then i
thought
can we mimic it instead can we make
artificial spider silk
back home i rushed to my computer eager
to trademark the name silk with a y
instead of an i
of course and was super disappointed to
find out
that in fact someone was already doing
it after the requisite time for
teenage sulking i picked myself up and
kept searching for my next velcro moment
as an aside that company was bolt
threads and they've already raised 200
million dollars
if i could come up with that idea as a
teenager what could society accomplish
as a whole
if we all just looked a little deeper at
nature what could we build
if we look to the designs of the plants
and animals around us for inspiration
now some of you are probably thinking
okay yes
spider silk and velcro are great but is
anyone else really doing this
so let's go through a couple more
examples so i can really give you a
taste of the potential
for the 2000 summer olympics in sydney
speedo unveiled a new bathing suit
modeled after
a sharkskin and 80 of the swimmers that
year wearing speedo's suit
meddled on the totally other side of the
spectrum
neural networks being developed by
cutting edge ai firms are in part being
designed after the neural networks in
our own brains
and the best part is it can be applied
to any industry you just have to know
where to look
building a swarm of drones look at how a
flock of birds can fly at 35 miles an
hour without crashing
or an architectural firm looking to
design a green building
can look at how a termite mound is able
to keep the same temperature
all year round without any access to
electricity
we've discovered 1.2 million species on
earth and some people think there's as
many as 8.7 million
think of all the potential for society
if we just look to the designs of the
plants and animals around us
but we humans are a pretty cocky bunch
build a couple skyscrapers invent ice
cream
and we're pretty sure of ourselves
we think we can just sit back and come
up with new ideas out of thin air
okay not us but like some humans
probably
einstein once famously said you cannot
solve problems by using the same
thinking
that you used when you created them and
we're all too familiar
with the problems that our current
thinking has created
there's climate change resource
depletion
pollution i'm here to propose that
biomimicry can help us think
differently biomimicry can help us break
into entirely new areas of innovation
we don't need to rely on our own
ingenuity anymore to solve these
problems
there's a million guides out there just
waiting to help us out
20 years ago human-centered design was
introduced on the ted stage
today it's expected knowledge in most
companies and major business schools
around the world
so now it's time for nature
nature-centered design we need every
advantage in our fight to save our
planet and our health
and biomimicry could be what tips the
odds in our favor
so what do you see that nature has that
we should be copying
what can you invent to help push
innovation further
what can you take home from a walk in
the woods what is your
velcro moment